wir sind jetzt etwa 620 stunden nach der
bundestagswahl seit den ersten prognosen
und was fehlt aus meiner sicht ist die
mut demut von der union demuth vom
vorsitzende der cdu armin laschet denn
schauen uns einfach nochmal die fakten
an die cdu die csu haben zusammen etwa
neun punkte verloren sie kommen auf dem
zweiten platz das ist ein fakt sie haben
im bundestag etwa 50 sitze verloren von
um die 250 auf unter 200 sie
ja sind schwächer als das linke lager
also schwarz gelb zusammen kommen etwa
auf 35 prozent die roten und grünen
kommen zusammen auf 40 prozent das heißt
die union hat diese wahl nach allem was
wir wissen verloren aber armin laschet
sagt er möchte eine regierung bilden er
möchte eine jamaika regierung anführen
und was fehlt ist die demut und
ich glaube wäre er diese ganze sache
anders angegangen hätte er gesagt
zunächst hat olaf scholz den wal auftrag
dann hätte es eine chance gegeben wäre
eine ampel-koalition die sondierung
dahingehend gescheitert dass man
irgendwann zu sagen können ja eine
jamaika regierung könnte dieses land
jetzt anführen könnte es aus der krise
führen aber das wird mit jedem tag sowie
armin laschet sich im moment verhält
schwieriger ich würde sagen mag während
ja olaf scholz wie so ein rubbellos ist
also die menschen haben sie jetzt
gekauft aber man weiß ja nicht welche
koalition ist ergeben wird am ende er
finde ich wusste man bei arminia schon
immer was man bekommt er hat nämlich vor
der wahl schon gesagt er müsste ja gar
nicht die meisten stimmen bekommen um am
ende kanzler zu werden hat schon vor der
wahl auf das beispiel 1976 hingewiesen
wir sind frage ich mich manchmal warum
uns das jetzt so überrascht weil er hat
das ja gesagt also sagen ich möchte
eigentlich gerne mit der fdp koalieren
er hat vorher schon gesagt er muss nicht
die meisten stimmen haben um eine
koalition zu bilden und jetzt kämpfte er
bis zum ende man wusste was man bekommt
aber das mit der demut ist ein guter
punkt finde ich weil es gibt ja noch
mehrere daten die ihnen zur demut
verpflichten würden die ihn auch
irgendwie anfassen und belasten müssen
er hat ja kein einziges faktum dass für
entspricht nicht ein einziges du hast
wesentliche genannt ich kann fortfahren
in nordrhein-westfalen seinem land die
cdu nicht gebunden in aachen seiner
heimatstadt ist die cdu drittstärkste
kraft also man kann fast sagen mit dem
selbstverständnis einer volkspartei
unter ferner liefen seine persönlichen
werte egal was man fragt also immer noch
fragen müssen nach den aber gut sitzende
anzüge an dann vielleicht hat er da
geworden wobei ich da auch zweifel ab
aber er hat nicht gewonnen bei sympathie
er hat nicht gewonnen bei tatkraft er
hat nicht gewonnen bei kompetenz er hat
jetzt neuerdings auch nicht gewonnen bei
der frage wer sollte die regierung führt
also ich weiß gar nicht in einem
sportverein ist es so dass du weg bei
niederlagen wenigstens sagen muss wir
haben sagen können müssen wir haben aber
weniger tore bekommen als dann der in
abstiegsnot ist kein einzige zahl die
für entspricht und urlaubsreise will
jeder naja da hatten ein
abschluss könnte ich ja spaß genauso
lange liste machen was alles fühlt ich
frage mich ja ist das schon ich mag mich
ja und das frage ich mich seit gestern
wenn millionen menschen in diesem land
jetzt wochenlang diesen die auch
teilweise fehlenden wahlkampf mitgemacht
haben und durch ihre straßen gefahren
sind und diese plakate gesehen haben und
da ging es immer um den kanzler und
jetzt ist gewählt worden und einer hat
mehr und einer hat weniger und es geht
irgendwie auf einmal gar nicht mehr
darum dass der der mehr hat kanzler wird
versteht man das eigentlich noch als
normaler mensch
also ich verstehe es nicht und ich
glaube dass tatsächlich das problem in
diese alters berühmte wort von der
alternativlosigkeit also scholz ist im
grunde die die bessere wahl neben lasse
das wollen viele leute auch nicht
begreifen ich habe selten einen so
emotionslosen menschen erlebt wie scholz
es fasziniert mich man kann nur hoffen
dass er wie viele wissenschaftler und
wir uns dass frau merkel ja auch
vorgemacht hat von einem solchen
intellekt geprägt ist dass er keine zeit
hat einmal leidenschaftlich zu lachen
oder in irgendeiner form zu erkennen zu
geben dass es einer gewissen inbrunst an
in diesen in dieses amt geht das macht
mir ein bisschen macht mir ein bisschen
sorge was ich heute fasziniert gelesen
habe sind die wahl die stimmanteile
unter den wahlberechtigten
unter den wählern sondern unter den
wahlberechtigten und da kommt die cdu
noch auf 18 prozent der wahlberichtigten
18 prozent der wahlberichtigten am cdu
gewählt 20 prozent der wahlberechtigten
haben
die spd gewählt interessant 9 prozent
der wahlberechtigten fdp 11 prozent der
wahlberechtigten die grünen das heißt
dass selbst die ampel koalition nur noch
40 prozent der wahlberechtigten abdecken
würde beide koalitionen haben unter den
wahlberechtigten in deutschland keine
mehrheit mehr egal wer regiert die
mehrheit der wahlberechtigten hat die
regierung nicht gewählt und das finde
ich ist tatsächlich eine total
dramatische entwicklung wenn wir wissen
die nächste regierung hat in deutschland
keine mehrheit diese gewählt hat
dramatisch ist sie nur wenn man sie zum
ersten mal erlebt also ich hab das
gestern hier irgendwann gesagt ich komme
aus dieser komfortablen zone meines
lebens in der die guten waren die amis
die bösen waren die russen es gab die
schwarzen es gab die roten es war so
übersichtlich es war überschaubar und es
war nachvollziehbar und man muss unsere
generation zu gestehen dass wir uns so
langsam reinstolpern in diese neue
wirklichkeit einfach ist es nicht aber
die neue wirklichkeit ist doch erst mal
relativ einfach nämlich dass man sich
die zahlen anschaut und sagt da ist ein
abstand von 1,6 prozentpunkten und dann
kann man noch hingehen und sagen liebe
spd ihr habt damit den ersten platz
geholt dazu gratuliere ich dir natürlich
wäre es ist jetzt fast beim koalitions
bein dass er immer erst mal artig hat
sich geändert in meiner lebenszeit also
mehr ist mehr und weniger olaf scholz
ist dann schafft die ampel zu fahren
aber neben der rat eine frage
interessiert mich findest du dass armin
laschet olaf scholz zum wahlsieg
gratulieren so ein absolut absolut er
sollte ihn zum sieg gratulieren bei den
hat olaf scholz auf herum und alles
andere ist echter demokrat da bin ich
komplett bei der julian aber dass armin
laschet jetzt versucht das zu tun was er
vor der wahl den wlan angekündigt hat
das war ja mit ansage dass er gesagt hat
ich muss nicht auf platz 1 der stimmen
das finde ich in ordnung er muss
gratulieren herzlichen glückwunsch olaf
1,6 prozent mehr ich gratuliere dir er
muss auch ein resümee zieht aber dass er
jetzt probiert mit bernburg und länder
zu sprechen am telefon hängt schreibt
uns noch nicht aufgeben will da muss ich
sagen das imponiert mir er habe das
hängt ja zusammen man kann jetzt alles
ich habe gerade listigen marie armin
laschet vorhalten und so
aber ich glaube nicht dass man ihm
absprechen können dass ein anständiger
kerl ist und deshalb würde auch er
wissen dass man einem sieger gratulieren
wenn ich auch und was man daraus lesen
kann ist dass er nicht glaubt dass der
der sieger ist also er selber hat noch
gar nicht rationalisiert dass das der
sieger ist weil er nämlich ständig schon
seine eigene koalition versucht zustande
zu bringen und das ist das eigentlich
dramatische dass so eine art
wirklichkeitsverweigerung oder er weiß
wenn er sagt das ist der sieger dann ist
er selber tot aber das wäre und demut
also dem bekannten der politik auch sehr
an die nieren gehen aber alle in einer
wirklichkeitsverweigerung wenn wir
unsere quoten bin ich keine ahnung
welche sendung ich mache dann sagen wir
ja früher war das so unser mehr leute
zugeschaut unserem die meisten zugesagt
jetzt sagt man ja moment wir haben aber
in der wichtigen zielgruppe der 3 bis 9
jährigen liegen wir ganz vorne und jeder
rechnet sich sein leben schön selbst der
focus rechnet sich seine zahlen schön
bild wird jedes mal am morgen radial
moment im vergleich zu oder wenn wir
zusammen sehen die klicks und online und
dies und das dann kommen wir auf eine
zahl und mit dem wir gut leben können
diese schirme regen erwartet werden und
nicht das könnte am ende mehr seien sei
eine zahl kann er sich nicht
schönrechnen nämlich das 1,4 millionen
wähler von der union zur spd gegangen
sind das sind direkt abgewanderte wähler
die früher merkel gewählt und das muss
man zur kenntnis und 900.000 zu den
grünen das
könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass eure
freunde die ihr kennt die cdu wählen auf
einmal die grünen wählen wein also ich
bin diesmal ich gegangen wenn das seine
kollegen lagerwahlkampf die haare schon
hat mega es gab ihn nicht kennen hier
ich kenne sogar ich weiß sogar wie
wohnen die das gemacht haben dann müssen
wir uns aber
wegen armin laschet also die haben
gesagt wird nein wird bringt wieso will
gegen armin laschet annalena baerbock
sagen die kann ich ja gar den konnex
kann ich erklären bevor ich die adressen
hoffentlich die nx ist das wenn man
armin laschet nicht zutraut das weiter
so zu der brecht und in etwas neues zu
verwandeln und dann haben die leute
gesagt also die grünen sind kreis lichdi
berbalk gibt uns auf den zeiger da habe
ich ein ganz guter mann das war auch
immer mit drin nun wir wollen es aber
jetzt mal anders haben und das war der
grund und das wirklich wirklich der kann
man diesen fehler das ist verzweiflung
aber dann hat armin laschet eben fast
eine million menschen zu einer
verzweiflungstat animiert
[Musik]